Donald Trump has indeed been reinstated  to Twitter after being banned for nearly  a couple of years by Elon Musk who  bought Twitter and reinstated Trump  based on the voting to a Twitter poll  that Elon Musk put out there but at  least for now it doesn't seem that  Donald Trump is going to go back to  Twitter in fact Trump posting a  screenshot of that poll untruth social  or as some know it truth Central and  says vote now with positivity but don't  worry we aren't going anywhere truth  social is special hmm  yeah do we believe that or is Trump not  going to be able to resist going back on  Twitter and if he does is it going to be  out of desperation because his 2024  campaign will be failing much to ponder